[musique]
archiver ce changement
épouse de notre pays
Et
[musique]
quand
s'il est comme ce soir, je suis stupide
j'ai allumé la télé plus fort pour qu'elle ne le fasse pas
J'ai entendu parler ici aussi il y a une semaine
s'est suicidée à l'ouest du tourment, elle a deux fois
elle s'est réveillée, elle l'a sentie aussi
peur parce qu'ils comprennent ce que c'est
cogne un
si vous encouragez constamment un enfant à parler
Ce Dota c'est la guerre, cette guerre c'est ce que je lui dis
peut-être plus rapide sur le psychisme avec une arme à feu que
Toute cette situation en elle-même est ce que j'essaie de faire
dire que quelque chose est tombé ça c'est tombé ça
a trouvé quelque chose qu'elle ne comprenait pas auparavant
fin
[musique]
ou
Monaco
[musique]